les circuits courts utopie ou réalité
pour sa troisième conférence a grillé
urba saint quentin en yvelines et les
réseau des médiathèques se sont penchés
sur la question saint quentin en
yvelines a choisi de prendre en compte
l'aspect agricole dans l'ensemble de son
projet de territoire comme une part
intégrante à la fois d'aménagement à la
fois 2
de développement économique et puis
également de vie citoyenne elle la
france compte un agriculteur pour 128
personnes à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un pur 11000 habitants les
circuits courts véhicules pas mal de
d'angélisme une part de d'idéalisation
parfois on peut penser que les circuits
courts vont résoudre tous les problèmes
alimentaires ou les problèmes et
questions agricoles et en fait
évidemment ce n'est qu'une petite part
de des modes de production
enfin des moyens de production agricole
trente deux exploitations agricoles sont
sur le territoire saint quentinois et
quenza maps ou le relais d'une
agriculture de proximité comme 100%
villepreux créé en 2016 et une centaine
d'adhérents à ce jour c'est pas si
simple de créer une amap de trouver des
partenaires et surtout de
le système amap fonctionne de manière à
ce que le la map soit là pour soutenir
les partenaires et particulièrement les
maraîchers parce que c'est quand même
une économique est fragile
une dernière conférence est prévue le 16
mai prochain ce dernier rendez-vous
s'attardera sur l'agriculture urbaine